We were about to go to bed
when I realized that we were all out of toothpaste.
So my husband went downstairs to make some.
Lucky is very precise in his measurements,
so he started out by measuring some bentonite clay.
He added that to a bowl with a tablespoon of water.
We weren't making a huge batch,
so this was more than enough.
He mixed until it was all smooth.
Broke a spoon in the process.
Then he moved on to measuring out some coconut oil
and adding that to our clay mixture.
He also added a teaspoon of baking soda.
He gave that a really good mix.
Made sure everything was combined
before he added the last two ingredients,
which were some stevia and peppermint essential oil.
We love our toothpaste.
Quite minty. So he added a lot of essential oil
before mixing that up one last time
and transferring that over to a glass container.
Everyone's teeth are different,
so this might not work for everyone,
but the smell of this and the texture of this,
I love having it on hand.